[Music]
these days eSports is biggest players
are basically nerdy rockstars they're
wearing thousand-dollar shoes driving
flashy sports cars and even starring in
overly obnoxious Doritos commercials
[Music]
life is pretty good for them especially
compared to a few years ago when
tournaments were held in sweaty
convention centers and all you got for
winning was a cool PC or a bag of rice
but long before then in a prehistoric
era there was one original superstar
gamer a trailblazing groundbreaking
neckbeard who not only won hundreds of
thousands of dollars and won luxurious
prizes but ended up changing the way
that we play games forever if you're of
a certain age and you like video games
Denis Thresh Fung is the Joe Namath of
video games now the eSports of today
emerged from a lot of weird primordial
uses but in the West we can point
specifically to the likes of doom and
quake and way back in the late 90s when
those games were most relevant there was
one undisputed champion Dennis Thresh
Fong was pretty much a living gamer
stereotype back in the early 90s he was
a college student who lived with his
parents and played a ton of doom and he
became pretty good at it so good in fact
that leading up to a Microsoft held doom
tournament in 1995 he was on a 1500 game
win streak a feat that led to a
newspaper referring to him as the most
lethal killer in cyberspace dude when I
was addicted to quake I would watch
demos all the time from this guy named
Thresh Dennis Fung there it is Dennis
Fong he was the best and while he was
playing before he retired he was the
best like he was so good that people
would watch his demos and try to emulate
his moves even that early on in his
career Thresh was making $500 per public
appearance from a peripheral company but
he leveled up pretty quickly just two
years later Thresh was making six
figures from endorsements and people
were paying him to write celebrity game
reviews on top of that he'd earned a
quarter of a million dollars in prize
money in just two years of pro play
because well he was winning everything
thresh was an eSports pioneer at a time
when eSport
wasn't even a word he was getting
sponsorships he was flying around the
u.s. to compete in tournaments and he
was clicking on heads he even laid the
foundation for the now iconic cringy
edge Lorde gamertags of today power oh
boy
sitting here with a big dick Stacey
hello adventurer suck mah dick that's
the name you chose Thresh is short for
threshold of pain which sounds more like
a Dethklok album than a thing you would
actually call yourself anyway back then
eSports tournaments were struggling to
put together the kinds of eye poppin
prize pools we see today so sometimes
they would offer the winner something a
little different
going into red and I elation thresholds
on top of the world the 1997 quake
tournament was one of the first major
national tournaments in the US and
whittled down 2,000 players online until
just 16 were left to play at e3 in
Atlanta but the top 16 weren't playing
for cash no they were playing for John
Carmack's Ferrari okay so you probably
have a handful of questions at this
point one who the hell is John Carmack
to where did he get a Ferrari three why
in the hell would he put it up as the
prize for a quake tournament well it
turns out that the answers to these
questions are all pretty nuts first who
was John Carmack
well he was obsessed with computers and
playing video games and at 14 years old
made [ __ ] acid out of thermite and
Vaseline to melt his school's windows to
steal all of their computers he got
arrested and a psychiatric evaluation
found that he was quote a brain on legs
with no empathy for other human beings
Wow a brain on legs Jesus Christ now
this might sound like a [ __ ] up thing
to say about somebody until you remember
what quake and doom are like
anyway remember when I said that doom
and quake were the biggest games in the
world well they work and unlike today
they made the people who made them into
celebrities Carmack teamed up with John
Romero Tom Hall and Adrian Carmack to
found in software in 1991 where they
proceeded to crank out hit after hits
first came Wolfenstein followed by dune
and then quick within five years of
being founded it effectively invented
polished and perfected the blueprints
for the first-person shooter genre you
can't underestimate what John Carmack
and John Romero have done for eSports
and I think it's a criminal shame that
no one has recognized in to those people
with lifetime achievement awards for
eSports because they are the daddies
they are the founders it but beyond that
they were also the guys that started
land-based eSports the fact remains that
their games without quake without doom
without hex and without Castle
Wolfenstein we don't have 3d games we
don't have first-person shooters we
don't have counter-strike which was
built on half-life which was built on a
quake engine by the way it goes without
saying but these games were stupidly
popular with each selling hundreds of
thousands of copies not bad for a small
indie studio run by four ko junkies alas
nothing lasts forever
over the years gaming Roman Empire
collapsed as its founders butted heads
Romero and Hall left to form their own
studio ion storm which eventually folded
and even in faded from relevance as
newer Studios rose up to take
first-person shooters for word anyway
where was I
Thresh Carmack Ferrari right so Carmack
was absolutely loaded thanks to the hits
he developed and so he did what any
twenty-something year old with more
money than God would do he threw his
money at fast cars
Carmack had so many Ferraris that he was
able to casually put one up as the grand
prize at the red and I elation event
making it up to that point the highest
value prize in competitive gaming
history after tearing his way through
the final 16 Thresh found himself in the
grand finals against entropy who ended
up being just another victim of his
dominance funny thing is I actually what
I'm known for as a gamer is a
I don't really get nervous you're calm
I'm pretty yeah it doesn't really bother
me and actually as I was playing this I
wasn't very nervous but but near the end
of it when I realized that I had won I
was looking and staring at the
reflection of the Ferrari and the
monitor and it kind of freaked me out
now there were just a few teensy
logistical problems with the grand prize
namely the fact that Thresh didn't know
how to drive stick and the fact that he
wasn't insured in the end Carmack not
only gave Thresh his Ferrari 328 but he
paid for his insurance coverage for a
year he wound up using it as he had it
sort of in the lobby of his company for
a while as kind of a conversation piece
and he did I think eventually wound up
selling it I think I got a message from
someone last year that still had it so
it's still functional at this point
after making his name as one of the
world's most successful gamers Thresh
went on to help found a slew of
influential websites and services that
ended up selling for millions of dollars
but his real injury legacy is actually
felt by every single person who plays PC
shooters today when most people started
playing games back in those days you
just used the keyboard and then over
time people realize that the keyboard
had a fixed rate of turn so if you want
to turn left you know it would kind of
go like that you wouldn't be able to
flick I found WASD on my left hand and
then using the mouse on the right hand
to be the most comfortable Thresh
pioneered using WASD as his movement
keys and after winning so many
tournaments with his setup Carmack paid
tribute to him by programming it into
quake as an optional config but in time
WASD transcended quake becoming the
default standard for the entire FPS
genre on top of that his legacy has been
paid tribute to in league of legends
where everyone's favorite bug zapper
swinging gould shares his moniker these
days eSports are a huge deal it's
growing every day tournaments are
getting bigger and bigger and our star
players are becoming actual celebrities
23 years ago Thresh wasn't so far off in
that he was so famous he had his face
drawn next to Bill Clinton's on the
all street journal' but it's been two
decades since then now that's a long
time in the real world but it is an
eternity in East once people have 2-year
careers and get called old and washed up
by the time they're 21 most of you young
uns out there don't even know Thresh let
alone remember his accomplishments
instead his legacy lives on in WASD here
it comes once again the first base is
adrenix gonna hit the ground there's
coal ports as earliest pioneers may have
changed the industry but maybe more
importantly they changed the way you and
I play games forever and that's worth a
lot more than a Ferrari you can't drive
you know last thing I'm gonna say is you
know obviously I think eSports has a
really really bright future and I'm
humbled that you know kind of the Hall
of Fame has selected me to be part of
this because you know really what it
means to me and it really does mean the
world to me that my small contribution
to the birth and growth of eSports will
be remembered in the future so thank you
so much guys
[Applause]
what we have we have every time dude
every time I'm a sucker for it and three
Windham and three why in the flying Oh